thank you it's uh wonderful to see so
many people here for a
domain driven design topic in python
there's a lot of content in this talk
and you'll see why in a moment i'm not
sure we're going to get through all of
it but i'm going to rattle through it
and you can come and talk to me
afterwards if you
need clarification on anything i talk
about
i'm going to start with a quick
introduction of ddd domains from design
what is it
anyway then i'm going to move on to
some strategic ddd topics ubiquitous
languages and bounded contexts then
we're going to go to the other end of
the scale and talk about the smallest
parts
the smallest simplest patterns in domain
driven design
value objects and entity objects
then we're going to move on to
aggregates which is a topic that some
people find very confusing at first when
they
first get into ddd then i'm going to
shift
gears and talk about software
architecture and
how the architecture of an overall
application
can be centered on a domain model then
if we have time i'm going to talk about
repositories
and domain events well what is ddd
uh a bit of a health warning though
there are no answers
in software design or modeling but there
are
plenty of choices to make and whenever
we design a software system
or design a domain model it's all about
making choices
and there aren't necessarily any right
answers so i'm not going to give you
right answers today
discovering good answers for your
context is something that's
very much up to you what we've noticed
is that domain driven design is
often encountered in classic enterprise
computing projects
which are nearly all written in on the
jvm stack
in java or on the dotnet stack in c
sharp
and some of the languages have picked up
quite a big ddd community
like f-sharp for example but we see
relatively little
ddd activity in python
which is a shame because python is a
great fit for ddd
there's nothing that is happening in ddd
that we cannot implement in python
domain-driven design is about distilling
a problem domain
down to its essence and python allows us
to produce
very low ceremony solutions and so
they're actually an
excellent fit to each other so
we're going to talk about how to bring
these things together
and hopefully you can get inspiration
from this and go away and think about
using ddd in your own projects so
one approach to learning ddd is to go
out and buy the original book
by eric evans which is what 15 years old
now from 2003
it's a very heavy blue book
it's almost completely indigestible
unless you've already been through a ddd
project
so this is not the right place to learn
ddd
it's a great book to read when you've
been through a couple of ddd projects
ideally one of which has failed
and then you'll understand what eric
evans was talking about
so this is definitely a book that you
will come to
in your journey with ddd but it is not a
good starting point
i later in the talk will refer you to
some
much better starting points for getting
to grips with gdd
so ddd is it's a philosophy for
bringing software closer to the problem
domain
we are coming up with software solutions
that are driven by the problem
rather than driven by technology by
involving domain experts
and it's a systematic approach which
involves some strategic design practices
i'm not going to really talk about those
today
a bunch of principles and some
guidelines rules
and patterns which i largely am going to
talk about today
ddd is not about specific technologies
it's very largely technology agnostic
technology is of course important but it
isn't the driver
it's not a heavyweight method it doesn't
imply that we need to do waterfall and
do all of our design up front
it's completely possible to use in an
agile context
and also it's not always appropriate
anybody who stands up at a conference
and tells you that you're doing it wrong
unless is a charlatan
all the advice you get at software
conferences is context dependent
and there are plenty of context in which
ddd is not
appropriate so you should be aware of
the context in which ddd works well
and be prepared to use it in those
contexts but be prepared to search for
other types of solutions
in other contexts so let's take some
pictures from eric evans
the uh the father of ddd if you like
this is very difficult to read so we'll
zoom in on part of it actually we'll go
back and zoom in on to this part
so the practices and patterns of ddd
are really broadly divided into two
areas strategic ddd
which are have a broader context
they're very influential on how a
project turns out or how a product turns
out
but they are not really related to the
kinds of decisions you're making every
day
as a programmer as a developer i'm going
to briefly talk about some of these
particularly bounded context and
ubiquitous language
and then there is tap the tactical ddd
patterns
which are these are the things that as a
developer as a programmer
you're dealing with day in day out
you're creating entities you're creating
value objects you're working with
aggregates so these are um as
programmers these are the things that
you'll interact with
much more frequently
so before we get into the tactical
aspects let's
just quickly look through the ubiquitous
language
and bounded contexts
so one definition of domain driven
design
by vaughn vernon is that ddd is
primarily about
modeling a ubiquitous language in an
explicitly bounded context
now that is actually a very deep
statement and it makes a lot of sense to
me
because i've been doing this for a long
time but i'm going to try and unpack
that
for you and what it means now all
domains
have a language which
people working in that domain used to
talk about the things in that domain
including ddd this is a kind of meta
ubiquitous language
these are the words we use to talk about
when i'm
giving this talk you'll hear me words
that use like uh use words like domain
and design and language and system and
context
because this is the ubiquitous language
of ddd but any
domain that you're working in will have
its own language
and the experts working in that domain
will have their own language
and one of the key things we need to do
in a ddd project is to learn
that language and rather than imposing
our own language on the domain
take the language from the problem
domain into our solution
so this is called the ubiquitous
language and
ubiquitous meaning to use everywhere or
being everywhere so one of the key
objectives of dddd is to create a
supple knowledge-rich design which calls
for a versatile
shared team language and that's not just
shared amongst developers
that's shared amongst everybody involved
and lively experimentation with the
language
it takes time to discover a language you
won't get it right first time
you need to experiment and discover and
refine
and be prepared to change decisions
you've made earlier
the ubiquitous language is context
dependent if you're doing
fighter aircraft avionics that's going
to have a very different ubiquitous
language to sending out people's utility
bills
a ubiquitous language is valid within a
context within a limit of applicability
and that is called the bounded context
i'll come on to that in a moment
she's by a community of domain experts
as a shared meaning
it's unambiguous it has a single meaning
and it's expressed
and this is really important the
language is expressed in the software
model
we use those words when we're writing
the software
and this helps reduce the distance
between the problem domain
and the solution domain and because the
solution is very close to the problem
any change that happens in the language
the domain will evolve over time should
be reflected as a change in the software
as a change in the model
so we need to strive to use the
ubiquitous language when we're naming
things in code when we're naming things
in databases when we're naming things in
tests
a banded context is the limit of
applicability of a ubiquitous language
and many larger domains will have
multiple bounded contexts within
them if you work for an energy trading
company there'll be an energy trading
boundary context
but there might be some kind of systems
administration boundary context where
different things are going on
and different languages apply in those
those areas so it's very easy to come up
with words which mean different things
in different contexts like the example
i have on the slide and one of the
failure modes of ddd projects for people
who are new to it is that they tried to
model everything as a single grand
unified model
rather than many smaller models
with narrower scopes of banded context
so when you're modeling you should
definitely exhibit a bias towards
separate smaller models rather than
one grand unified model for your domain
because if you build a grand unified
model of
the domain the larger domain it will be
sub optimal for everybody
and nobody will have a good time working
with it and you'll spend a lot of time
wondering why the things that are going
on in the real world don't map
very neatly onto the things that you've
expressed in your software so
models will exist within bounded context
you should prefer to have multiple
bounded contexts for
anything other than trivial domains
the context is the scope of the language
we have separate
segregated models and independent
autonomous implementations you don't
even have to write them all in python
right maybe another language is
appropriate for some of these models
and ultimately these will these bounded
contexts of language will align with
technical components
so if you have if you identify three
bounded contexts in your domains
it's a really good idea to have three
systems right if you try to map that
onto
two systems or four systems you're
setting up yourself for difficulty
so ideally they should align with
technical components
and be loosely coupled and then you're
gonna have to do some work
which i'm not gonna talk about further
today in context mapping
in terms of how concepts in one domain
map to another
and a context map is both a conceptual
thing but ultimately it needs to be a
piece of software
that is able to move information and
share information between these domains
mapping from concepts in one domain to
concepts in another
for example you might have a user in one
branded context but that might be a
customer
in another branded context they are
clearly very related concepts but you
might wish to model them differently
let's go back to the other end and look
at value objects
these are just about the simplest things
that we the simplest pattern
in tactical domain-driven design
and value objects are used to measure
and describe things in the domain
so we're trying to measure or describe
characteristics like a currency value
or a telephone number
equivalent values are interchangeable we
don't actually care about the identity
of the object
when we're dealing with value objects we
care about the value of the object
they're comparable by value and they
lack an intrinsic identity
if we have a string which contains
someone's name
and another string which contains the
same name the fact that they're equal
is fine the fact that they are actually
different string objects is irrelevant
okay they are a name they're
self-contained
and normally they're encapsulated and
owned by entities which we'll come up to
next it's very good practice to make
your value objects immutable
which means they the instances of them
can be shared
so we have some really nice value
objects in python already things like
date time and string
they are immutable and shareable
um generally speaking though you should
avoid using
neat value objects like integer or float
or string
you should try to build some kind of
domain specific abstraction
around those types
the reality is is that your actual
problem domain does not have things in
it called string
and does not have things in it called
integer it might have something in it
like a currency
amount or an amount of money or a
duration
yeah so
strive to make them immutable easy way
of doing that is to lean heavily on the
built-in immutable types in python
tuple frozen set stro etc
validate them in the initializer dunder
init or dunder new
you might be using dunder new here
because you can share instances
because they're immutable you can do
interning
getters with property remember to
override the equality
operator in python 3 i don't think you
any longer need to override the
inequality operator you get that for
free
give them a useful thunder wrapper
think about whether rich comparisons are
necessary to implement for that time
quite often they are
consider preventing mutation by
overriding
then the set atra to prevent people
mutating the object
and of course always give your types a
useful then destroy and consider a
dunder format as well that's quite often
useful for many of these value types
and use side effect free functions to
produce new values
so if you do need to modify a value
object
rather than having a mutating method on
that
have a method which returns a new value
object with the modified value
so date time is a good example of that
in the standard library
date time is immutable you can create
new date times by say replacing the
day with a new number but it doesn't
actually mutate the date time object it
returns you a new date time
with it all the other numbers are the
same but the day is different
so that's a very good approach to follow
and consider using what i call named
constructors
so using class methods so that you can
actually
it gives you an opportunity to express
the domain language the ubiquitous
language
in your class when you're creating
things
and i've also already mentioned
interning with dunder new so here's a
very simple
um value object it's an email address
this is quite a naive implementation
but it's uh simple enough to show on a
slide
so i have a class method which is a
named constructor so i want to construct
a an email address from string i have a
done during
it which accepts a local part and a
domain part there are the parts either
side of the at symbol
i have done the straw and i've done the
wrapper they're not very interesting
i've implemented done the eq for
equality
and then the hash which needs to go
along with dunder eq
and i have two properties for read-only
access to the local part and the domain
part of the email address
and then i have a single method here
replace which allows me to either
replace the local part or the domain
part or both
and notice that it returns a new email
address object
so you can kind of fake mutation if you
like by always returning new objects
so value objects are very simple to
build in python
the thing is to focus on immutability
and in fact most of your model
can be implemented in terms of value
objects usually it's a very
good place to start and the reason
immutability
is so important is because it makes them
so much easier to reason about
and test and debug because there's
essentially no behavior in them
beyond some initial validation
let's move on to entity objects which
are the
the next level of sophistication
so entities are different because they
represent things that are
distinguishable
by identity even if they are completely
equivalent in value
the fact that one of them is a different
instance to another one is an important
thing
the identity needs to be stable over
time
so an object an entity object cannot
change its identity and
it needs to be unique within the bounded
context of
that particular model and for entities
life cycle is important
it's important when the entity is
created it's important how the entity
evolves over time
and it's important if the entity is
deleted that's not something we often do
or deactivated which is more common is
to say this entity is no longer in use
they are they're more often mutable
although immutability is always to be
preferred
and they tend to be composite they tend
to be made of other entities and value
objects
so in python it's important to
distinguish between
creation of an entity
only have it happens once for a
particular entity
an instantiation of the entity as an
actual live object in the system you
might register a user with your system
as an entity
and that registration only ever happens
once but that
user might be put into a live python
object
millions of times over the lifetime of
their interaction with the system
so we need to distinguish between
creation and instantiation
creation needs to happen via a factory
function
which it needs to establish all the
invariants all the things that have to
always be true
about an entity it probably needs to
either create or get hold of a unique id
for that entity from somewhere
you should i've discovered to my cost
you should really strongly prefer what
are called
factless ids not an id that comes from
the domain
just cook up an id somehow it could be
an integer it could be a uuid a guide
whatever
but don't make it some fact from the
real world because things that you think
are immutable in the real world
often aren't so prefer an internally
generated id
and often the factory can just be a
module scope factory function
sitting next to the class
and it's sitting next to the entity
class don't do anything on the other
hand is used for instantiation of the
entity that might
get called many times over the lifetime
of that particular entity but each time
creating a different
instance of that don't do anything to
accept all the i
the id and all the state it's already
validated by the factory at this point
so
the then doing it tends to be very
simple it's generally just assigning to
attributes consider maintaining a
version
an object version an entity version
within the
entity and possibly also an instance id
it is very important that dunder in it
always succeeds because you might be
calling dunder in it when you take
an existing entity out of storage and
you never want that to fail
yeah it needs to be in a in a valid
state
so i generally use an entity based class
i'm not going to read through
this in detail partly because it's too
small on my screen here
um but we have you notice the dunder
init here
is very straightforward it's just
assigning to
attributes it's not doing any validation
work because we're assuming that
validation work has already been done
elsewhere
in the factory and
nearly everything else that's on here is
machinery to do with
version keeping and a marker for whether
the entity has been discarded and
really put beyond use which is generally
a better technique than actually trying
to delete the entity
um that's an abs that's a an abstract
bass class which i
tend to carry around something similar
like this um
an actual entity here which subclasses
entity this is a customer
um we call the superclass constructor we
assign an
an attribute and we have
some getter and set of properties and
notice that the queries and mutators
check the liveness of the entity as this
entity be marked as discarded because if
so this needs to fail
notice that the factory function there
on the right register customer
that gives us an opportunity to express
the domain language
again we have two opportunities to
express the domain language now
once in the entity name as a noun in the
class name
and once in the name of the factory
function
so it isn't just something like make
entity or sorry make customer
we actually can say register customer
because that's what we're actually doing
that's
maybe the language that's used in the
domain
okay so at the most basic level
domain models are constructed from
graphs
of entities shown in the rectangles here
which own value objects and the
immutable value objects may be shared
so their entities are identifiable they
have a life cycle
they're probably mutable and they're
composite and the values
measure describe quantities
they're equivalent interchangeable
self-contained and preferably immutable
so this is very simple and
almost any python system whether it's
built using ddd or not
will involve a domain model something
like this
so what ddd brings really is what
happens next when we get to
aggregates so let's look at aggregates
so here's the previous picture again
what
is an aggregate well
you might look at this and think well
it's just a cluster of
closely related entities and that's
partly true
but it is it's much more than object
clusters
although an aggregate may have more than
one entity
often aggregates will have only one
entity and there's
there are good reasons to prefer having
only one entity
aggregates really are consistency
boundaries
we are going to require that the model
is always consistent
within an aggregate but we are going to
allow
the model to be eventually consistent
between
aggregates okay so it turns out that in
your code
aggregates don't really exist you don't
have to write any code for your
aggregate
it's really a convention that you follow
about how you use your entities
so this is a part where people get a bit
confused because we have this
very very important idea the aggregate
which isn't actually reflected as a
class a separate class necessarily in
the code
but this idea of consistency boundaries
is really the most important idea here
you'll notice that every aggregate
shown in this kind of orange color has
a one entity which is special
that's called the aggregate root entity
and it is the entity that is responsible
for maintaining consistency
within the aggregate because it's
responsible for maintaining consistency
it is the entity which hosts mutating
commands
on that aggregate you can put mutating
commands on the child entities within
the aggregate
then it gets more awkward to maintain
consistency amongst
the other entities within that aggregate
the aggregate is responsible for
maintaining its own consistency
so while it's generally fine to put
query methods on
entities wherever they are in aggregate
i find it works well
to only put the
mutating command methods on the root
aggregate because then it's in a good
position to maintain
consistency within the aggregate
notice also that the root aggregate is
special because it is the
target for any inbound references to
that aggregate
we are not allowed to have deep
references to entities within another
aggregate
if we want to refer to a specific sub
entity we must provide enough
information
in that conceptual reference to go to
the root aggregate and then navigate
within the aggregate to the
a particular child okay so
that's a very important idea the
inter-aggregate references are to
the root and all into aggregate
references
are by root entity id
ideally this the opaque factless id that
we talked about a moment ago
this is important because then i can
instantiate part of my model one
aggregate without having to instantiate
all the other aggregates that it depends
on
okay it's fine to have reg use regular
python references within the aggregate
and it's fine to have the whole
aggregate instantiated simultaneously
but with between aggregates we need to
use
an id and generally speaking the factory
is responsible for creating a whole
aggregate so it may configure an entity
with particular child entities at the
time it is created
so the factory factories facilitate and
um aggregate creation and allow us to
express the ubiquitous language
and they hide the construction details
such as entity id
generation getting the aggregate
boundaries right
is really tricky and you probably won't
get it right first time
you need to iterate look for conceptual
holes
which can be instantiated queried and
modified
independently of other parts of the
model look for
parts of the model that is useful to do
work on
alone use the delete rule of thumb i'll
come on to that in a moment
and as i mentioned already we enforce
consistency at all times within an
aggregate but we are going to allow
eventual consistency between aggregates
possibly with asynchronous updates
try to keep aggregates small many
or perhaps most even will should have
only one entity from a python point of
view i find one module per
aggregate is a pretty good way of
organizing things
i might have multiple entity classes
within that if it's a more complex
aggregate
or if it's a very complex aggregate i
mean end up promoting that module to be
a package in its own right
that's generally how i find myself
organizing the code
as i said already the command method
should be on the aggregate route
with only query methods on the child
entities
it's okay for methods to accept
transient references to other aggregates
as regular python references but you
shouldn't keep hold of those things
it's okay to use them for the purposes
for the lifetime of a single method call
to do some work but you shouldn't keep
hold of those references
above all you should remember that your
models need to be useful
and not necessarily realistic i've seen
a lot of time
wasted on producing incredible models
of reality which turn out not to be very
useful for the actual problem the system
is solving so try to keep things you
know try to keep things
as sim simple but as complex as they
need to be to solve the problem
so i talked about how finding aggregate
boundaries can be tricky i'm going to
show you a quite
simple example if you think of something
like trello
kanban board software for that
let's think about some entities that are
involved here we have a work item
in my model here i'm going to allow work
items to independ
to exist independently from the kanban
board on which they are on
we have a board and we have some columns
on the board so we have three
entity types here it's a very simple
model
and the board owns some columns and the
columns
and some work items maybe
and thinking about how aggregate
boundaries could be here we could do it
this way
but this kind of feels wrong doesn't it
you wouldn't model it like this
because you wouldn't you wouldn't
separate the columns from the boards
into different
aggregates because you need to keep
those things consistent with each other
but i've already said that work items
can be allowed to exist separately
this might be okay i could go for this
but i think the right answer if there is
one is something like this
the board and the column are separate
entities but they live together within
the same
aggregate and work items are their own
aggregates because they're allowed to
exist
independently the trick here is to a
simple trick to follow is to use the
delete rule of thumb
and ask well if i start deleting things
what else necessarily needs to be
deleted
so if i delete the whole board it
doesn't make sense for me to keep the
columns around
okay but it might make sense for me to
keep the work items around
okay so the delete rule of thumb is
quite an effective way
of getting at least a first pass stab at
where your aggregate boundaries need to
be
and we would allow our internal
reference within the aggregate there
the board to the column to be a regular
python reference
but we'd want to the columns to know
about the work items by
work item id and of course once i've
finished on my whiteboard then i might
want to
make this more formal but i wouldn't
often make the effort of drawing
pictures like this
any questions and aggregates before i go
on i'm just going to take a couple of
questions now because there's more to
come
so yes
i can repeat the question the question
was how prevalent is the use of uml
in domain modeling my answer to that
is the uml is sees hardly any use
in any project including ddd projects
i would say it's down it's well under 10
percent
okay i have this particular diagram
because it comes from a training course
a real project would i draw this
probably not
i have worked on projects where we build
uml models
after we've written the code for
documentation
but i would not recommend building
models like this or and i certainly
wouldn't recommend trying to generate
any code from the model
i think you're just wasting your time so
i mean you know we can still be quite
agile with this and the model will still
need to evolve quite quickly
perhaps and if you're dragging some
horrible diagram behind you while you're
doing that you're just costing money
for example i'm talking to a product
manager or whatever
then like he gave me the specification
but then i found there's another thing
here another thing there
and the original design you know messed
up yeah
so
how long it takes to do some of this
stuff i mean i would go through cycles
like this that last a few days
yeah we're not i'm not talking about
people doing weeks and weeks and weeks
of design here
you know small bounded context small
aggregates you can
work on parts of the system you can
divide the work up
yeah you can delegate to people so
you don't need to have some big design
effort at the front for this to be
a useful technique yes
for the video how should i find the
borders between microservices
i am going to mention microservices in a
moment
because i'm going to talk about software
architecture now
so can i come back to that shortly okay
so let's talk a little bit about
software architecture
um nothing we've seen here
requires complicated frameworks or
proprietary infrastructure or
fancy architectures or enterprise
anything
a lot of ddd is appreciate is associated
with the kind of heavyweight
enterprise computing it doesn't need to
be like that
at all
i find it very interesting the way we
approach building things in the python
community
compared to the way things are built in
other communities
in which i've also been involved
i think to some extent we tend to build
models
in spite of some of the frameworks we
have to work with
and like i said ddd is a choice and
sometimes using those frameworks is the
right thing to do
but i would also like you to think about
the alternatives and that's really what
this talk is about
it's about getting you to think about
some of the alternative
approaches so this picture here is from
i think the not the ddd book itself but
a shortened version of it that came out
in 2004
and if you look at what this
architecture is about this layered
architecture we have a user interface
which these days tends to live in the
browser we have an application
we have a domain model and we have some
infrastructure databases and
actual computers i guess
and then you match that up against for
example a pyramid web app
where we have some javascript front end
in the browser we have pyramid
we've got your model which is maybe
implemented in terms of something like
sql alchemy
or a django app where we have the
browser
and the model and we use the django aum
right so more than 10 years well
probably around 10 years ago now in the
ddd community everyone was crazy about
using object relational mapping
technologies to build their models um i
was at a conference in
london about five years ago and eric
evans
the man behind ddd came out with this
wonderful phrase
which i just think is fantastic the
object relational mapper takes two
brilliant ideas object-oriented
programming and the relational model
and incapacitates them both and i think
this is this is very true you end up
making such horrible compromises
for your object model and your
relational model in order to get them to
work nicely together
so okay this is fine i can stand up here
and rant about
the problems of using object relational
mappers or modeling frameworks but
what's the alternative well people have
been talking about alternatives for a
very long time
bob martin talks about the clean
architecture
notice in the middle of this he has
entities and around that use cases you
can think about controllers
um and then look at look what's in the
outside
blue ring there we have the ui on the
outside which you would expect
but we also have the database on the
outside which you maybe don't expect we
tend to think of the database as kind of
being in the middle underneath
everything else
they've moved the database to the
outside alexa coburn
another signatory of the agile manifesto
proposed the hexagonal architecture we
talked about ports and adapters
the application is in the center but
again look at where the database is it's
on the outside
my favorite presentation of this is
jeffrey palamo's
online architecture again domain model
in the center then we have
domain services application services and
the user interface on the outside
but again infrastructure and the
database is also on the outside
so this approach is called externalizing
the infrastructure
it's um it places the model at the
center
your application is not about databases
right it's about some problems some
domain problem you are solving
that should be the most important thing
in your software the database is just
something you need to do that it's just
a tool
so the alternative to expressing your
model in terms of somebody else's
framework over which you have
probably little or no control is just to
use plain old python objects
just write some python code and own all
of it
right don't become beholden to somebody
else's technology
if your project is successful it's going
to be around for a long
time it's going to be around for longer
than probably many of the technologies
you might choose to use
so as a software architect you should
think about that
it's a risk so mitigate the risk and
don't depend on
other people's frameworks where you
don't need to so we can have a pure
python domain model
and we can prefer not to build that
domain model in terms of
persistence frameworks because
persistence
isn't a domain concept go and talk to
your users about persistence
they won't even know what it means it
doesn't feature in your ubiquitous
language
what on earth is it doing in your domain
model
so i've talked about bounded context and
a bias towards separate models
let me just mention how answer the
microservices question
so in terms of microservices
i would draw it like this based on
geoffrey palomar's diagram from a decade
ago
and say each of these microservices
represents a bounded context
it has it's self-contained it has its
own model
it doesn't care about the other models
it communicates with messages to
other part other boundary contexts okay
so they could be written using different
technologies they can be written using
the same technology
but each one is optimized for a
different part of the
greater domain does that make sense
to answer your question yeah okay
good
i really am going to get through 100
slides in 60 minutes
okay so let's think about repositories
so i've said that we need to not build
models
or we should consider not building
models in terms of
um persistence frameworks that doesn't
mean you shouldn't
you know think about your context that
it's a very large number of use cases
where building a crud app using your
favorite object relational mapper is
exactly the right thing to do
and i'm not railing against that i'm
just trying to open your eyes to
some of the alternatives here
but ultimately we do need to store the
data right it's not enough
just to hope that our computer is turned
on and never gets turned off
so we need to have repositories
indicated by the the red circles here
and a repository is somewhere where we
can put an aggregate
and go back and get it later how do we
know which aggregate we want
well it might be in the simplest way
just by its id
maybe it's referred to by another
aggregate and we have these id
references between aggregates and so one
aggregate can go to a repository for
another aggregate and retrieve it by id
or it might be some more complex domain
specific query
so repositories store aggregates they
retrieve aggregates
we usually have one repository per
aggregate type
and they are an abstraction over the
persistence mechanism
and they are very architecturally
significant
so generally we want to better put have
an aggregate that we've instantiated put
it into a repository
get hold of one based on some criteria
and
persist changes to some store
whatever that store is and possibly also
remove aggregates from a repository if
they're
no longer required it's very tempting to
at this point get involved in database
transactions and things like that you
should
resist that temptation transactions are
something that belongs in the
application
layer not in the domain model the domain
model
shouldn't be concerned with database
transactions
why well go and ask your users
whether database transactions is a thing
in their domain
and how they talk about that in their
domain language and they'll have no idea
what you're talking about so it doesn't
belong in the model
are many ways of building repositories
we can have what are called collection
oriented repositories
uh in the python sense you can think of
a repository that behaves like a
dictionary where we can retrieve
if you imagine building a class which
has an interface that looks like a
python mapping
looks like a dictionary and we can go
and fetch things by id
and how it actually pulls those from
storage is
an implementation detail so it's
certainly possible
to make dictionary-like repository
interfaces
or we can have a more what's called
persistence-orientated
design where we put an aggregate in we
remove an aggregate
and there's a much more explicit notion
of saving if you like
with a persistence oriented repository
there or there are other repository
types as well
i'm not going to talk about event
sourcing today but
that is certainly a an option here
probably a too popular option so
collection oriented repositories are
very easy to use but they can be quite
complex to implement because you're
trying to put a kind of dictionary
abstraction on top of some machinery
that might be quite complex
and they're a good fit if you're using
something underneath like sql alchemy
which can be an intrusive dependency
persistence oriented repositories are
much simpler to implement
they're a good fit with no sql stores
like mongodb
but they do require some diligence on
behalf of the application programmer
because you have to remember to actually
save the stuff
into the repository
and as i mentioned there are other
options so generally we will have an
abstract repository
inside the domain model why because
the different aggregates need to be able
to get hold of each other somehow so we
need to have a repository
interface in the domain model but we
defer
the implementation of that repository to
outside
in the infrastructure layer and because
of that relationship that dependency
inversion
repositories need to be instantiated
even further out
in the application layer there's some
pictures coming up that
makes this more evident
so you need to consider testability in
fact this is very good for testability
because you can build
fake or very simple in-memory
repositories for testing
testing in your domain model although
not testing your large application
some advice here it's very tempting to
thank you it's very tempting to
implement generic selected queries
something like uh like i have on the top
right here like repo
employees with and then some lambda that
says
age greater than 60. that's really nice
to use as a programmer
it seems like but you're not really
expressing the domain language here
and also it's very difficult to
implement that in terms of different
repository implementations
how do you convert that language lambda
to a sql query
we have technology to do that but it's
probably not a technology you want to
necessarily get involved in it's much
better to you to
take the opportunity to express the
domain language and have
a repository query method which is
something like
uh on the employee's repository
something like eligible for early
early retirement because that's the
actual question that's being asked
okay
so in terms of how i might organize code
for something like this i would
generally have multiple packages i have
an application package
which is the outer layer if you like an
infrastructure package which contains
concrete repositories
and then the a package per
bounded context which actually contains
the domain model
so they have this kind of dependency
relationship so the application depends
on the infrastructure
and the infrastructure depends on the
domain
not the domain depending on the
infrastructure so this is the key
dependency inversion in the clean
architecture
or the onion architecture so if you're
using something like sql alchemy this is
probably the exact opposite of what
you're doing today
here's another picture superimposed on
the onion
here so i have
uh just under 10 minutes left so
let's crack on and
talk briefly about domain events and uh
so we've just done like an entire day of
training
right without the exercises um so
now we're on to day two in the last five
minutes
so let's see how we get on um domain
events
and modeling time so what is a domain
event it's capturing the memory of
something interesting which happens in
the domain
right now interesting means interesting
to the domain people
not interesting to software people right
so if your disk fills up
right that's not a domain event it's
something your logging
needs to know about but it's not a
domain event right if a new customer
registers with your system
that's a domain event okay so
generally speaking um aggregates will
emit events
this allows us to model time explicitly
they're significant to the business
they're first-class members of the
domain model this is something that was
really missed back in 2004 at the
beginnings of ddd
but the tdd has become very
event-centric
recently and of course it's the
foundation of event sourcing
and projections and process managers
which i'm not going to talk about today
but you have to have domain events for
these things to work and they allow us
to establish causality
between things and of course if you have
them they are wonderful for logging
although that's not their
primary purpose
okay so given the time i'm gonna go to
this one
so you should name your events in the
past tense
so money deposited not deposit money
they should be immutable value objects
themselves why should they be immutable
well you don't want people going around
screwing around and changing the
attributes of something that's just
happened
right it needs to be an immutable record
uh it's good practice to get a time
stamp in there somehow monotonic
hopefully
um and include the aggregate root id
of the aggregate that created the event
and any any information required to
navigate to child entities
i generally define my event classes as
nested classes within
the entity the root entity
and you may consider organizing them in
the same way we do with exception
classes so that you can
listen to particular events based upon
the inheritance hierarchy
and prefer a publish subscribe messaging
system rather than subject observer so
something like pi pub sub within your
boundary context of your application is
fine
you may want to republish those method
those messages to a message bus
for other bounded contexts to listen to
and act upon but within your single
bounded context it's probably just going
to be quite a simple
python application and you can just use
very simple technologies for that
um i'm not going to talk about that
because i'm going to be out of time
shortly i do want to cover this though
descriptive events versus prescriptive
events
so it's very tempting to um
write methods which modify the model in
some way and then
emit an event which describes what's
just happened
that's the kind of natural thing natural
way to write things and you probably
do that a lot the problem with that is
what you actually did and what you just
published
don't necessarily match those things can
get out of sync you know you forget
to one of them gets changed you forget
to update the other one
and then your events aren't a reflection
of what actually happened
a much better approach is to
in your command methods which mutate the
model
is to describe the mutation you would
like to make in an event
right and then apply that event
as a way of mutating your model and then
those things cannot diverge they have to
be the same
so probably last bit of code here
descriptive events on the left
i
you can see i mutate the underscore name
attribute to the new value
and then i publish an event the
alternative approach
in the in the name setter here i create
the event object and then i do
self dot apply event
okay and that is what actually causes
the mutation to happen
and that dispatches to the function at
the bottom of the screen which actually
does the work
so just to summarize um
we've actually in an hour
quite a big chunk of everything in the
ddd book
and it will take you a lot more than an
hour to read it i hope you've
had a bit of a flavor of um
of what's in there
so we've covered domain events entities
value objects
aggregates factories repositories the
layered architecture
we haven't covered services and there
are lots of other things which sit
around
dd on this diagram like process managers
how do we model long-running processes
that affect the model where the user may
come and go during the course of that
process
occurring so we've uh we've done pretty
well
in an hour i think uh i'm just going to
close
on some references for you to go and
look at
other things if your if your interest
has been peaked
by what i've said today there is the
blue book remember what i said earlier
it's uh not the best starting point
a very lightweight starting point is
vaughn vernon's book domain driven
design distilled
that's about a centimeter thick the blue
book is about
five centimeters five or six centimeters
thick
um if you choose to read only one book
read this one um domain driven design
sorry implementing domain driven design
by vaughn vernon
and the tweet there has a suggested
approach to reading this book
which is to read chapters one to four
and then go away and try and build
something and come back and use the rest
of the book as a reference